Hallo, schönen guten Tag. Ich bin Frau Sahin. Ich bin auf dieser Station als
Assistenzärztin tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch
führen. Falls Sie Fragen haben, können Sie mich jederzeit unterbrechen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden? Ja, klar, gerne.
Zunächst benötige ich Ihre persönliche Daten. Wie heißen Sie? Mein Name ist Frau
Krüger, Sabine Krüger. Sabine Krüger. Können Sie Ihre Nachname und Nachname kurz buchstabieren?
Mein Vorname ist Sabine. Mein Name ist Krüger. Wie alt sind Sie und wie ist Ihre
Geburtstatum, Frau Krüger? Mein Name, also ich bin geboren 1986 am 2. November.
Okay, Sie sind... Ich bin also 39 Jahre alt. 39 Jahre. Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel
wiegen Sie? Ich bin 1,65 Meter groß und ich wiege aktuell 70 Kilogramm. Frau Krüger,
was führt Sie heute zu uns? Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich seit ungefähr drei Wochen
habe ich Herzklopfen. Das stört mich sehr. Ich schwitze sehr viel und habe auch 5 Kilo
Gewicht verloren. Wir haben unwillkürlich. Ungewollt, ja. Ungewollt. Und wie ist es mit
Ihrem Appetit? Mein Appetit ist gut. Hatten Sie... Sind solche Beschwerden am ersten Mal
getroffen? Hatten Sie vorher auch solche Beschwerden gehabt? Nee, ich habe das zum
ersten Mal. Zum ersten Mal. Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie schwitzen. Schwitzen Sie
tagsüber oder auch in der Nacht? Meeres. Auch nach Schweiß. Haben Sie Fieber gemerkt?
Haben Sie Ihre Fieber gemessen? Ich habe es nicht. Okay. Wie ist es? Haben Sie Luftnot
bemerkt? Leiden Sie unter Luftnote? Nein. Haben Sie Husten? Nein. Frau Krüger,
ich weiß jetzt nicht, haben Sie in letzter Zeit auch Zittern bemerkt? Ja, ich habe
so ein leichtes Zittern in den Händen. Seit wann? So eine Woche ungefähr. Sie haben
gesagt, dass Sie sehr viel schwitzen. Fühlen Sie sich durstig? Wie sieht Ihre
Haut aus? Vielleicht struppiger als sonst? Nee, eher feucht. Feucht? Feucht und warm
ist meine Haut. Ich habe nicht mehr Durst. Ich trinke normal. Ist Ihnen in der
letzten Zeit also schwindelig geworden? Nee, nicht wirklich. Okay. Wie ist es mit Ihrem
Stuhl und Wasserlassen? Wasserlassen ist normal. Stuhl ist häufiger geworden. Kann man
sagen, dass Sie an Durchfall leiden? Nee, kann man nicht sagen. Ich bin normalerweise immer
einmal am Tag auf Toilette, aber mittlerweile gehe ich dreimal am Tag auf Toilette. Und wie
sieht Ihre Stuhl aus und wie ist die Konsistenz? Normal. Also Sie haben kein Blut bemerkt.
Haben Sie Blut bemerkt in Ihrem Stuhl? Nein, habe ich nicht. Leiden Sie an chronische
Erkrankungen? Nein, ich habe keine chronische Erkrankungen. Nehmen Sie regelmäßige Medikamente?
Ich nehme sehr selten Medikamente ein. Sehr selten. Ist Ihnen in der letzten Zeit
Kopfschmerzen aufgetreten? Nein, nicht wirklich. Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Essen,
besonders feste Nahrungsmittel? Nein. Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden? Ja, meine Mandeln
wurden als Kind entfernt. Sonst? Nein, sonst habe ich keine Operationen. Frau Krüger,
bekommen Sie Ihre Regelblutungen regelmäßig? Ja. Wann haben Sie am letzten Mal Ihre
Regelblutungen gehabt? Das ist schon etwas länger her. Wenn Sie mich so fragen, ist das
schon ein bisschen... Ich bin im Verzug. Also es müsste schon längst in der Periode sein,
aber das habe ich noch nicht bekommen. Also Sie sind noch nicht beim Irrenfall? Nein,
normalerweise habe ich die regelmäßig, aber ich habe jetzt, wo Sie gefragt haben,
bemerkt, dass ich jetzt im Verzug bin. Wie bitte? Normalerweise hätte ich jetzt schon
meine Periode haben müssen, habe ich aber nicht. Könnte es sein, dass Sie schwanger sind?
Nein, kann ich ausschließen. Und Sie wissen nicht, am letzten Mal waren Sie am letzten Mal Ihre
Regelblutungen gehabt? Das war vor ungefähr fünf Wochen. Ist bei Ihnen Allergien bekannt?
Ich habe eine Hausstauballergie, ansonsten habe ich keine Allergien. Wie reagieren Sie
darauf? Mit Gaumenjucken niesen. Ist bei Ihnen auch irgendwelche Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein, ich kenne keinen. Frau Krüger, rauchen Sie? Ich rauche ja. Wie viele Zigaretten rauchen
Sie pro Tag oder pro Woche? Ich rauche ungefähr zehn Zigaretten pro Tag. Seit wie
vielen Jahren? Fünf Jahre. Trinken Sie auch Alkohol? Gar nicht. Ich trinke gar kein Alkohol.
Ich habe noch eine Frage, aber bitte nehmen Sie es nicht persönlich an. Ich muss das fragen.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen? Aktuell nicht, nein. Aktuell nicht, aber vorher? In meiner
Jugend habe ich mal probiert. Sie haben schon probiert. Frau Krüger, sind Sie vollständig
geimpft? Ich denke schon. Sind Sie in letzter Zeit gereist, verreist? Ich war in Australien im
Oktober. Also ist schon fünf Monate her. Ja. Gibt es irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen in
Ihrer Familie? Mein Vater und meine Mutter haben beide Bluthochdruck und meine Schwester,
sie hat ein Herzproblem. Sie hat Rhythmusstörungen. Sie hat Rhythmusstörungen.
Aber bei Ihnen ist eine Herzkreislaufkrankheit nicht bekannt? Nein. Gott sei Dank. Sind Sie
verheiratet, Frau Krüger? Nein, ich lebe alleine. Sie sind ledig, Sie leben alleine. Ich nehme an,
dass Sie auch keine Kinder haben. Ich habe keine Kinder, nein. Was sind Sie als beruflich
tätig? Ich bin Lehrerin. Haben Sie viel Stress in der Arbeit? Ich habe viel Stress,
aber ich mache die Arbeit gerne. Sind Sie in letzter Zeit mehr nervös als sonst? Ja,
so ein bisschen. Ja, so eine innere Unruhe habe ich. Ich bin auch schnell gereizt.
Sie sind auch schnell gereizt. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen? Ich schlafe auch sehr
schlecht. Sie schlafen auch sehr schlecht. Leiden Sie unter Einschlaf oder Durchschlafstörungen?
Ja, beides eigentlich. Beides eigentlich. Warum wachen Sie auf? Das weiß ich nicht.
Wegen der Unruhe müssen Sie auf Toilette gehen? Nein, doch Toilette muss ich nicht,
aber vielleicht wegen der Unruhe, vielleicht wegen dem Herzschlag, ich weiß es nicht.
Haben Sie schon etwas für den Herzschlag eingenommen? Nein, ich kenne mich damit nicht aus.
Sie haben nichts eingenommen. Waren Sie schon bei Ihrem Hausarzt wegen dieser Beschwerde?
Nein, war ich auch nicht. Und wie heißt Ihre Hausarzt bzw. Hausärztin? Das ist die Frau
Dr. Schmidt. Mit DT? Richtig. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Haarausfall bemerkt? Nein,
habe ich nicht bemerkt. Also Frau Krüger, das sind die Fragen, die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Also bis jetzt die Angaben, die Sie mir angegeben haben, also deuten auf eine
Schilddrüsenüberfunktion. Okay. Dafür müssen wir erst sie körperlich untersuchen und auch
Blut abnehmen und auch bildgebende Verfahren durchführen. Ist das was Schlimmes? Also ich hoffe nicht,
aber natürlich können wir jetzt nicht ganz genau sagen. Erst müssen wir unsere Untersuchungen
durchführen, damit wir sicher sein. Dann besprechen wir mit Ihnen auch die Therapie.
Also es kann auch was Schlimmes sein, ja? Also man kann jetzt in diesem Stufe nicht sicher sein,
aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit besteht. Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist niedrig. Okay. Ich kann
nicht etwas sicheres sagen, bis wir die Malignitäten ausschließen. Aber die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist niedrig. Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen. Was ausschließen? Die Tumorkrebs,
etwas Bösartiges auszuschließen. Aber Sie vermuten schon ein Tumor? Nein, ich vermute
jetzt nicht. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist niedrig, wie ich gesagt habe. Aber natürlich müssen wir
Untersuchungen durchführen, um sicher zu sein. Verstanden. Okay. Gibt es sonst Fragen?
Darf ich eine Frage stellen? Ja. Haben Sie bemerkt, ob Ihre Augen hervorgestellt sind?
Die sind nicht hervorgestellt, nein. Danke schön. Sie sind leere, denn leitet sie unter
Konzentrationsstörungen? Nein, aber ja so ein bisschen Nervosität und Gereiztheit.
Haben Sie Hautfarbveränderungen bemerkt? Ich habe kein Hausfein. Hautfarbveränderungen?
Hautveränderungen, ach so, Entschuldigung. Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt. Entschuldigung,
Sie haben gesagt, Sie müssen auf die Toilette dreimal täglich seit ungefähr seit einem Woche.
Wie ist die Menge? Weniger als sonst. Weniger als sonst. Was heißt das? Weniger als sonst,
zum Beispiel normal ist täglich total weniger als sonst. Verstehe ich richtig? Also es ist mehr,
aber wenig. Es ist öfters, die Frequenz ist öfters, aber weniger an Volumen, Menge. Okay,
ich habe eine Frage. Ist jugendlichen Drogenkonsum triffungsbedingter anamnestisch wichtig? Nein.
Okay, dann fangen wir an mit dem Gespräch. Frau Schein, hallo. Hallo, ja. Schönen guten
Tag Herr Dr. Obatz. Ich habe eine neue Patienten aufgenommen. Ich würde sie Ihnen
gerne vorstellen, falls Sie Zeit haben. Ja, gerne, bitte schön. Also unsere Patienten
heißen Sabine Krüger. Unsere Patienten ist eine 39-jährige Patientin. Sie heißt Sabine Krüger.
Sie ist 1,65 Meter und 770 Kilogramm schwer. Frau Krüger klagt, dass sie seit zwei,
seit drei Wochen Herzklopfen hat, mit begleitenden Schwitzen. Sie hat auch
Nachschweiß. Und sie berichtet auch, dass sie in den letzten drei Wochen unabsichtlich
5 Kilogramm abgenommen habe, obwohl ihre Appetit gut sei. Sie habe keine Fieber bemerkt. Sie
habe keine Fieber bemerkt, obwohl sie, aber sie schwitzt. Sie habe auch, sie habe nach
nachschweiß, wie ich gesagt habe. Die Fragen nach Luftnot, Husten wurden verneint. Sie
habe, also sie berichtet, dass ihre Hände leicht zittern und ihre Haut ganz normal,
feucht und warm ist. Die Fragen nach Stuhl, sie habe bemerkt, sie habe berichtet, dass die,
dass sie in den letzten Wochen häufiger als, häufiger als als Gewöhnliches auf die
Toilette gehen. Normalerweise gehen sie zu Toilette einmal pro Tag, aber in den letzten Wochen
habe sie berichtet, dass sie dreimal auf Toilette gehen. Der Stuhl Farbe und Konsisten sei normal,
aber die Menge sei niedrig als sonst. Sie habe keine Wasserlassenprobleme begleitet.
Obwohl diese vermehrte Stuhlgang, habe sie berichtet, dass sie nicht durstig ist und
normal trinkt. Sie hat auch berichtet, dass sie viel Stress hat, dass sie stressig ist,
Nervosität und Unruhe fühlt und sie leidet auch unter Insomnie. Die Fragen nach Vorerkrankungen,
Vorerkrankungen wurde verneint. Sie sei in ihrer Kindheit, bei ihr sei in ihrer Kindheit
Translektomie durchgeführt. Sie nehme auch keine regelmäßigen Medikamente ein.
Nehmen Sie die Pille ein? Die Pille danach habe ich nicht gefragt.
Fangen Sie nochmal nach. Als Frauen sollte man immer nachfragen.
Sie haben recht, das habe ich bemerkt. Die Frage nach Schwangerschaft wurde verneint.
Sie hatte ihre letzte Regelblutung vor fünf Wochen. Sie sei allergisch gegen Hausstaub
und sie reagiert darauf mit Heuschnutfen. Sie habe keine Unverträglichkeiten. Sie
rauche zehn Zigaretten pro Tag seit fünf Jahren. Sie trinke keinen Alkohol und sie
hatte nur einmal ein. Sie habe nur ein paar Mal Drogen probiert in ihrem Jugendalter.
Sie sei vollständig geimpft und sie sei vor fünf Monaten nach Australien
verreist. Außerdem erwähnte die Patientin, dass ihre Vater und Mutter an arteriöle
Hypertonie leiden und dass ihre Schwester an Herzrhythmusstörungen leide. Sie sei
ledig, habe keine Kinder und sie lebt alleine. Sie ist als Lehrerin tätig.
Was haben Sie für eine Verdachtstheagnose? Die anamnistischen Angaben deuten am ehesten
auf Hypothelose. Als Differentialdiagnose kommen also stressbedingte Nervosität.
Er hat schon gesagt, dass sie in der Arbeit Stress haben, obwohl sie gerne ihren Beruf
machen. Es kann auch eine Herzrhythmusstörung sein. Vielleicht habe sie auch arteriöle
Hypertonie, die noch nicht festgestellt ist. Was machen Sie zur Bestätigung Ihrer Verdachtstheagnose?
Erst würde ich den Patient natürlich körperlich untersuchen. Ich würde erst die
Vitellparameter messen. Dann würde ich auch den Thyroid untersuchen. Wie machen Sie das?
Also ich werde von hinten der Patienten die Thyroid abtasten. Die Schilddrüsen?
Ja, die Schilddrüsen abtasten. Und dann nehmen wir natürlich auch Blut ab. Wir würden die
Thyroidhormone messen. Welche Werte nehmen Sie ab? Also TCH und Freies T3 und T4. Und auch die Antikörper.
Wie heißen die? Antitpo. Und? Und Trap. Nicht Trap, Trag. Mit K. Und dann muss man unbedingt eine Sonographie machen.
Von was? Wie bitte? Von was eine Sonographie? Von Schilddrüsen. Ah, okay. Von Schilddrüsen.
Von Walcom. Ja. Und wir können auch eine Gehirnermati durchführen. Eine was? CT. Muss man nicht unbedingt machen.
Ja, muss man nicht unbedingt machen. Warum? Um eine Hirnanhandgröße, Vergrößerung aufzustehen.
Das machen Sie aber vom Labor abhängig. Wenn das Labor auffällig ist, wenn das also eine höhere Stufe ist,
das heißt, dann muss man überlegen, um einen MRT vom Kopf macht. Nicht ZITZEL. MRT vom Kopf.
Das machen Sie aber erst dann, wenn Sie die Blutwerte haben. Ja, ja, genau. Ganz genau.
Was erwarten Sie denn in den Blutwerten? Blutdruckwerte. Nein, Blutwerte von den Schilddrüsenparametern.
Was erwarten Sie? Wie werden die Werte sein? Wie wird das PSA sein?
Also die freie T3 und T4 soll erhöht und die TCH soll erniedrigt sein. Genau. So was erwarten wir.
Ja, das erwarten wir. Genau. Dann wissen wir auch warum, wenn wir Antikörper auch haben.
Wenn wir aber zum Beispiel Werte haben, wie TSH ist erhöht und FT3, FT4 ist auch erhöht,
dann kann man überlegen, ob man vielleicht einen Tumor hat in der Hirnanhandgröße, wie Profuse zum Beispiel.
Dann kann man einen MRT machen. Wenn die Blutwerte nicht miteinander passen, dann muss man eine Stufe höher überlegen.
Ja, ganz genau. Ganz genau. Gut, Sie denken also, Sie haben eine Hyperthyriose. Ist eine Hyperthyriose gefährlich?
Also wir müssen dafür Biopsie machen. Nein, ich meine nicht, ob Sie einen Tumor haben, sondern ist eine Hyperthyriose gefährlich?
Also das ist nicht eine gefährliche Krankheit. Man kann es mit Medikamenten im Griff haben.
Richtig, aber es ist gefährlich. Eine thyrotoxische Krise ist gefährlich.
Okay, wenn es unkontrolliert ist. Wenn Sie einen Herzrasen haben, eine Herzfrequenz ganz hoch, das kann schon gefährlich sein.
Ja, das kann gefährlich sein, aber das ist doch nicht heilbar, aber wir können diese Krankheit im Griff haben.
Aber sie ist eine potentiell gefährliche Krankheit. Ja, natürlich. Richtig? Ja. Wem wir es nicht im Griff haben.
Ganz genau. Und was machen wir, damit wir sie im Griff haben?
Also wir würden Medikamente, es gibt Medikamente, die schildrosen Hormone vermindern.
Was gibt man da? Propilthiouracil und es gibt auch Methymosol, die ich weiß.
Was gibt man? Propilthiouracil. Ja, richtig.
Okay. Und man kann auch Betablocker verschreiben für die Herzrasen.
Das stimmt auch, ganz genau.
Tiamazol, Kabimazol wird man hier meistens geben in Deutschland.
In der Regel. Tiamazol, Kabimazol. Okay.
Das gibt man hier in der Regel in Deutschland. Gut.
Kann man auch Cortison geben, wenn man eine Thyretoxikrise hat.
Das ist wichtig, auch so müssen wir den Betablocker. Okay.
Aber jetzt brauchen wir nicht einen Cortison.
Sie hat hier keine Thyretoxikrise, sie hat wahrscheinlich nur eine Hyperthyriose.
Herzfrequenz, wenn sie bei 110, 120 ist, das kann man noch gut behandeln.
Aber Herzfrequenzen über 160, 170, die neigen dann zur Dekompensation des Herzens.
Deswegen sollte man das umgebracht haben. Ja.
Was ist die meiste Ursache für eine Hyperthyriose bei Frauen?
Orthoimminische Krankheiten. Welche zum Beispiel?
Also es gibt Gravis, Hyperthyroid. Ja.
Also ich kann mich nur daran erinnern.
Man sagt hier auch Morbus Basido. Ja, die andere Name ist Morbus Basido.
Genau. International Graves' Disease.
In Englischsprachigen Raum in Deutschland sagt man Morbus Basido.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Ein Problem. Sehr gut. Ja, Ultraschall haben Sie gesagt.
Und dann muss man gucken, ob sie auch eventuell einen Knoten hat,
das auch eine Autoimmun-Homontproduktion machen könnte.
Das werden wir dann im Ultraschall sehen. Aber die Diagnose ist eine Hyperthyriose.
Das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht. Ihr Deutsch ist sehr gut.
Ja, meine Aussprache ist gut. Weil ich Deutsch in meiner Kindheit gelernt habe.
Ah, okay. Man merkt das. Sehr gut.
Ja, vielen Dank. Aber ich muss noch viel üben.
Ja, ich finde das sehr gut. Sie haben das richtig gut gemacht.
Vielen Dank. Gibt es sonst noch Fragen?
Das war ein einfacher Fall.
Morat, kann ich eine Frage stellen?
Wir wollen nur relevante Dinge vornehmen.
Es gibt nicht viele Probleme mit diesem Fall.
Wie ein Oberarzt vornehmen kann, kann man uns ein Beispiel vornehmen?
Der Patient kommt uns hierher, hat diese Übung,
ich denke an diesen Tone, die Viteradiagnostik, die Therapie,
ich denke an diese Dinge.
Ja, natürlich.
Sein Arzt hat etwas mehr Allergien erwähnt.
Ich glaube, das muss man nicht in detail machen.
Ich berichte über eine 39-jährige Patientin, Frau Krüger.
Sie stellte sich heute in der Ambulanz vor mit Herzrasen, Unruhgefühl,
Schlafstörungen, ungewollte Gewichtsabnahme von 5 kg innerhalb der letzten 3 Wochen.
Sie hat zudem eine gesteigerte Stuhlfrequenz.
Sie hat keine relevanten Vorerkrankungen.
Auch in der Familienanamnese gibt es keine relevanten Vorerkrankungen.
Sie berichtet, dass sie ein Herzrasen verspüre.
Sie hat keine relevanten Vorerkrankungen, keine relevante Vormedikation.
Als Beruf ist sie Grundschullehrerin.
Auslandsaufenthalt wurde in den letzten 3 Monaten verneint.
Keine relevanten Allergien, bis auf eine Hausstoffallergie.
Meine Verdachtsdiagnose ist eine Hypertereose.
Ich werde diesbezüglich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Ich werde Blut abnehmen, die Schilddrüsenparameter,
sowie die Schilddrüsenantikörper.
Ebenso werde ich einen Ultraschall der Schilddrüse durchführen.
Die Differentialdiagnose ist schon mal eine Differentialdiagnose.
Ich werde noch eine psychische Differentialdiagnose hinzufügen.
Was macht ihr als Therapie?
Ob man abnehmen kann oder nicht?
Als Therapie würde ich eine thyrostatische Therapie mit Cardia Matsul einleiten.
Und die Laborparameter im Verlauf überprüfen.
Und ein inneren Medizinkonzil oder ein endokrinologisches Konzil?
Ich bin Internist, deswegen würde ich das nicht machen.
Aber für uns vielleicht?
Ein internistisches Konzil ist ganz gut.
Internistisches, nicht endokrinologisches?
Das muss man nicht unbedingt machen, weil man kann nicht.
Das muss man nicht unbedingt machen, weil man kann hier in Deutschland die Schilddrüse selber gut behandeln.
Wenn man aber nicht weiß, warum das so ist, wenn sie zum Beispiel ein Problem in der Hypophysie hat,
ein Hypophysienadenom zum Beispiel, dann sollte man die endokrinologen mit einziehen.
Oder wenn man Probleme hat, die Schilddrüse einzustellen.
Oder vielleicht bei der Sonne, denke ich, bösartig.
Nein, auch nicht. Muss man nicht endokrinologisch machen.
Man kann erstmal, muss man, man muss unterscheiden zwischen endokrinologie und endokrinisch chirurgisch.
Das ist unterschiedlich hier in Deutschland.
Es gibt einmal endokrinologen und einmal endokrinochirurgen.
Die machen die Operation der Schilddrüse zum Beispiel, die spezialisierten Kliniken.
Und endokrinologen benutzt man in der Regel sehr wenig in Deutschland.
Also man hat auch sehr wenig Kliniken, die endokrinologie haben. Ganz wenig.
Das ist ein sehr guter Klinik.
Für diese Patienten sollte man das Gegevenfels-Sinti-Grafik nennen?
Das können wir. Aber das ist ein sehr guter Klinik.
Das ist ein sehr guter Klinik.
Aber wenn man etwas wichtiges sieht, dann ist die Syndikrafik wichtig.
Aber die Syndikrafik ist wichtig.
Wir machen nicht die Hypertioge-Joghurt.
Wir machen bevor Oytioge-Joghurt.
Das sind die Syndikrafik.
Ich weiss nicht.